à en perdre la tête le dernier film de
richard attenborough les ombres du coeur
qui sort mercredi prouve que l'équation
l'équation pardon est bien possible
anthony hopkins un brillant professeur
de littérature s'éprend d'une jeune
romancière qu'interprète debra winger
nicole cornu langlois et jean-françois
chevet ont rencontré les acteurs et le
réalisateur de cette histoire qui est
une histoire vraie
rooney
l'homme n'est versée
le main dessus
il nourrira les n'osera
car ce soit
un amour par 10 pour ce professeur
conférencier réputé auteur de romans
religieux coincé dans un monde stérile
et routinier
c'est un homme qui vit très protégé avec
son frère c'est un intellectuel brillant
souverain dans son de même la
littérature dans un collège un univers
très sécurisant bref la scène vive a
explosé par l'arrivée d'une femme
extraordinaire une américaine loyal très
combative romancière également jog
reichmann entretenu une correspondance
avant cette rencontre avec cet écrivain
qu'elle admire et qu'elle va déranger
en vertu de la loi des contrastes à
vendre et non je crois que ce n'était
pas un coup de foudre au sens classique
pas romantique mais il avait un
sentiment profond
l'un pour l'autre et une véritable
complicité intellectuelle des bras est
aussi fantaisiste et facétieuse que joy
et anthony en perd son flegme
britannique
pour richard attenborough c'est un film
optimiste malgré la fin douloureuse
je pense que le soleil n'est pas là de
l'autre côté de la colline semblait
hélas au dessus de nous larry doit être
élevé à sa plénitude
vous devez être préparé à souffrir car
on ne peut pas avoir l'un sans l'autre